[Music]
check out the moves on this strip of
polymer
it may look like a party favor but the
method used to shape it
has a more practical future researchers
have found a way to
program flat strips of pasta to morph
into familiar 3d varieties
3d pastas need extra packaging to fit
their distinct shapes
making them harder to transport and
leading to waste
transforming pasta from flat to 3d
could solve those problems
the researchers began by flattening
dough made of semolina flour
an ingredient of traditional italian
pasta
then they honed them into strips scored
with grooves
adjusting the grooves depth and spacing
changed the strip's shapes
as they swelled and settled in boiling
water
different designs turned into saddles
curls and bow ties
the researchers fed the test data into
computer models that could replicate the
process
they believe machine learning could
automate the technique
making it easier for food companies to
design and deliver
3d pastas the next step is testing other
morphable foods
such as the gelatin found in wagashi a
popular type of japanese dessert
imagine the tasty possibilities
you